Hello
bitches.
Yeah,
Dad,
dad.
Dad is a real sweeping brush that people
from both sides like to use,
right?
The people in the right,
like do you use it on the liberals?
The liberals like to use it on
conservatives.
We like to paint people like real
obvious,
put up,
you know,
put them in a box,
make sure we can categorize them.
Yeah.
So mean.
I swear I said,
I said,
well,
I think I got,
I think I might have accidentally
started a little bit of it because I
said,
look,
all you have to realize is there's just
a disenfranchised part of America that
feels like they're not being
represented.
And then immediately I think Sarah got
jumped on me and she was like,
Oh,
you're talking about the racist?
And I was like,
I don't know.
You can't say that.
You can't say that I voted.
I'm not now,
by the way,
I voted for fucking Hillary.
So I'm just seconding what ha what I'm
noticing out of an election.
So I,
but I,
you know,
I,
I thought it was good of her to stand
her ground and to,
and to whole end just say her point and
not tried to back pedal and,
and I,
I appreciate that,
but well,
you know,
problem is the problem with that saying
that anybody that voted for trump is a
racist.
The real,
the real problem with that is because
the only other alternative is Hillary
and Hillary was very flawed.
That's just the way it is.
You know,
it's not,
it's not an anti woman thing to think
that someone who has all the ties to
corruption that she apparently does.
I mean you can go into it all day long
if you want to.
Do you want to like look at the Clinton
Foundation or any of the other crazy
shit that those people are involved
with?
It's kind of legal,
you know what I mean?
It's not really breaking any laws.
So like you can get away with doing all
that stuff,
but all of it is learned.
Oh,
deleted emails and all that.
Like why did you doing like what is
this?
Yeah.
And I think,
I think there was a large portion of
America who just didn't want to share
their opinion cause they didn't want to
be called a name.
So
there's real concerns too.
And people don't want to say this.
There's real concerns about her health.
Really.
She hurt her head in 2012 because she
blacked out.
She,
she blacked out,
fell,
fainted,
and hit her head really bad,
like really bad.
And um,
apparently she was fucked up for like
six months and this was 2012.
That's only four years ago,
man.
And that's a really significant head
trauma.
And she was very eloquent and the
debates,
she's really articulate.
I thought she kicked his ass and the
debates,
I honestly did.
I thought she came off smoother,
especially that second one.
Like he would say some crazy shit and
she would smile.
I thought she handled it great and she
was so much more eloquent and so much,
uh,
so much more so much better economy of
words.
The problem is,
is just,
it's so hard to,
to trust that she's telling you the
truth.
You know,
there's just too many things that she's
been like.
The difference between that Komi Guy,
what he said she had done with her email
and what she said she had done and you
play them back and forth.
You ever seen the video when they do
that,
it's pretty shocking.
You know what he says is very different
than her descriptions of what he says.
You know what he says is like she
violated some laws and what most people
thought in the,
apparently in the FBI,
it's one of the things that people got
upset Komi apparently from this article
I read at least they were saying that
the people in the FBI were very
disappointed because they thought that
he should have pressed charges.
They thought that when they looked at
all the evidence and all the stuff that
he talked about,
that he admitted that she had done that
you can't do it with classified data.
She had violated all these laws,
like if you were a regular person,
if you were real regular enlisted person
and you violated those same amount of
loss,
dude,
you'd be fucked.
You would be fucked fill.
They'll really puts you in a Goddamn
cage.
100% looks like,
I know this sounds silly,
but she just like,
they said,
hey,
we'd like to see her emails,
and then she just got rid of them all.
She deleted them all.
She deleted 30,000
emails and she did it after a subpoena.
At least some of them have to say,
I didn't know it was after a subpoena to
see how many find out how many emails
she deleted after the subpoena.
I don't know the absolute specifics of
it,
but it's just,
it's my point is it wasn't like she was
this awesome alternative,
you know,
so people that wanted change and they
felt like what Hillary represented is a
part of that big system as well as she
says her words and is a stately,
she is,
and she's a much better representative
of America in some ways than he is,
but she's just too tied to corruption.
Like all of this stuff that she's done,
like all the,
the,
the experience she has in government,
all that should be on her favor in her
favor.
But for a lot of people it wasn't this
time for a lot of people that would
like,
this government is just too intertwined
with these businesses that support it
and pay it money and they,
they're going to all these different
foreign countries and getting paid
exorbitant sums of money to talk.
It's like Bill Clinton was getting like
a half a million dollars to fly to these
countries that are all these like,
like serious like civil rights
violations on,
on their people.
Yeah.
There was like some thing that Clinton
had done.
We kept trying to push this one through,
see if he could find that there's this
one like dictatorship that he wanted to
go into it.
He wanted to go and do speeches and they
were like,
no,
you can't go there.
Like you're not supposed to visit that
place.
These,
these people are doing things we don't
look we don't agree with.
And he's like,
yeah,
I gotta go over there and I'm going to
do due to speech.
So let's just try to get like,
he just wanted to do that speech.
He just wanted that Cheddar.
That's,
I think it's,
what's interesting to me now is,
is the,
the population on twitter,
at least of people,
my friends that voted for hilary that
are now just saying,
fuck,
fuck the rest of the country.
Fuck,
I'm out.
This sucks.
It's like,
like,
did you see that the Canadian website,
the immigration website broke.
It crashed.
Brokes all the Americans were like,
fuck this,
I'm moving to Canada.
Has anyone ever done that though?
Fuck yeah.
You think fuck yeah.
Especially Vancouver.
Oh yeah.
Warm blankets like Seattle.
It's basically just
like Seattle,
seattle.
But I mean like weather wise is pretty
similar.
Probably identical.
But there was something different about,
about Vancouver that Seattle doesn't
have.
What's that like a,
I almost like this,
um,
like colonial,
like richness,
this European richness that,
do you know that bridge driving into
Vancouver was kind of big lions and
yeah.
And you're like,
oh,
this just looks like Lord of the Rings.
He like,
it looks like it could be in Germany and
that everything's a little more lush or
a little more overgrown.
I don't know if Seattle,
see I like sad.
I'll love Seattle,
but the downtown's look similar,
but even still like the downtowns in
Vancouver,
the food's always seems just a little
bit better than Seattle.
Did you ever do?
How?
Man,
that's a tough call.
They're both pretty fucking awesome.
You can't have shitty food and the
Pacific northwest.
Yeah.
You know like Oregon,
like Portland,
Portland,
and other places.
They have some fucking bang banging
food.
Do you ever go to that?
You ever do a go to that little taco
trucks?
The has?
Yes.
Do they have a
ty cheeseburger?
It's a cheeseburger with that like satay
sauce,
that peanut butter sauce.
Holy Shit,
and it's super spicy.
It's got Serratia and it to fucking
love.
God.
Damn.
It's good.
Bill Clinton sought State Department.
Okay.
For paid speeches related to
North Korea and the Congo.
He wanted Congo.
He's an animal.
They're cutting kids' hands off in the
Congo.
I respect his game.
He's like,
there's a lot of paper for me over
there.
I get to go get it.
I guarantee you when he,
when she got elected,
he was like,
fuck,
I guess she'll be around my house a lot
more.
Look at this.
It says
the FBI about the deleted emails between
March 25th and March 31st three weeks
after the subpoena.
The campaign now says it only learned
when the emails were deleted from the
FBI report.
Hmm.
Wow.
How many emails?
Oh my God.
30,490
work related emails on December 5th,
2014 and chose not to keep 31,830
emails.
She deemed personal.
Well,
that's interesting.
She,
by the way,
do you know how difficult that would be?
I have 33 unopened emails.
33,000
on the open emails and my thing.
And sometimes I try it,
it's just like spam and I try to clean
it out and it's a fucking nightmare.
Yeah.
It's not an easy to clean that out.
You're like select all,
delete.
But then you still the only taste where
they're like 800 yeah.
So if you've been paying attention to
all these people's reactions,
everyone's trying to like figure out
why,
why trump won.
It's really fascinating.
It's fascinating to see people freak
out.
It's fat.
People at crying,
people are fucking cry.
Oh they stormed out of a school in
Arizona.
The kids marched out of a school to
protest the president elect.
Whoa,
this is,
no,
but there is a weird,
like there was a weird energy when trump
gave his speech last night.
It was almost like the bully saying stop
hitting yourself.
Stop hitting yourself.
Like he was like,
he was like,
now we can be like,
it was kind of weird cause he has not
been like super inclusive.
And then all of a sudden he's like,
we need to heal together.
And you're like,
hey,
you totally feel that way.
But like part of me goes out there.
Is there a part of him that fucking
hates everyone that doesn't like him?
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
He certainly mean he's,
look,
he's a super businessman and super
businessman there.
They're like their game players that
play in a game.
So if you move towards them,
you know,
and you make a move,
they want to make a move to county,
you're moving fuck you up.
Like that's Donald Trump's personality.
That's why he sues all those people that
uh,
you know,
he's involved in altercations with.
He just fucking squash this shit.
He doesn't,
he doesn't like,
you know,
if people are talking shit about him,
but that's when once he become
president,
like you got to let all that go.
Like you have to.
Yeah,
you got to let all that,
you can't be tweeting johns to it at one
30 in the morning calling him a pussy.
She watched that video.
God,
yet it's hilarious.
He can't be tweeting johns to her at one
30 in the morning calling him a pussy
when you're in your sixties.
What the can't,
he can't do that.
Can't do that anymore.
You definitely now,
now that you're the president,
please stop doing that.
Don't do it.
You can think it,
but don't do it.
And even if you think it,
why even bothering?
What'd he care?
They've got to get rid of his twitter
immediately.
Nope.
He No.
Please bleeding.
He's get 'em keep tweeting.
Who Cares?
Why not?
Oh Dude.
Political correctness just took a
missile to the Dick.
Now,
do you think,
do you think that's good or bad per
standup on unquestionably good.
Unquestionably good in every way.
Shape or form.
Really?
Yeah.
It's good because he's going to do some
goofy shit.
He's going to say some ridiculous things
a week.
I mean it right now.
If someone,
if you said something like,
I like to go up and grab them by the
posies,
everyone would be like,
I,
that has to be acceptable because half
of America is not offended by that.
You seat,
I'm a believer in that.
The president in a lot of ways shapes
the mindset of the country because it's
just a natural thing that happens in
tribes.
You know?
If you have one fierce tribal leader in
a tribe,
guarantee you the warriors that are in
that tribe will also be fierce because
they'll be under the guidance of the,
the one wild fucking guy.
I mean,
that's how,
that's how like fierce armies get put
together.
You have to have a bad ass fucking
general.
Well,
when your president is this guy who
rarely gets riled up about anything,
he's not emotional at all.
He's super articulate and really well
spoken and he's a great orator.
That's Barack Obama,
right?
I mean,
that's what you would think of when you
think of like a presidential person.
He's probably the most presidential guy
we've ever had as president.
But then you go with trump,
like he's not doing that at all.
Like he's,
he's just rocking it at a totally
different way.
100% yeah.
He's
doing it like a businessman.
He fuck with him.
He's gonna fuck with you back.
You know,
you fucking piece of shit.
Jon Stewart,
you pussy to it.
It's real name is Lima was one 30 in the
morning.
But that's the kind of guy that can
fucking finance campaign for president
all on his own and when,
yeah,
that's crazy.
A month.
I mean,
forget about whether you think it's a
good thing for the country or bad thing
for the country.
It might be the greatest success story
ever.
It might be like the greatest upset of
any contest ever.
100%.
There's no bigger upset ever.
Right.
Like what do you think the odds were
when Donald Trump first entered the race
in Vegas?
That he would eventually become
president?
What do you think the odds were?
I remember watching,
um,
Seth Meyers State of the Union address
and he said,
Donald Trump's here,
Donald Trump said he's voting as he's
running as a Republican.
I thought he was running as a joke and I
doubled over and I thought,
I remember thinking to myself,
what,
what an idiot.
Hilde,
he could never be pres.
I literally thought he could never be
president.
And then to think that that's a fucking
reality.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
Has any celebrity other than um,
well Ronald Reagan,
Ronald Reagan's one I was curious about
because they said that,
I don't remember the election,
I was too young,
but they were saying that despite the
fact that he had already been governor,
cause that was like kind of like he who
he had been an office,
they were shocked that anyone would vote
for Reagan.
They thought he was a fucking joke.
And Dude,
he destroyed Mondale.
Like I look at those county by county
polls where they show you what the
counties voted.
It's really fucking interesting cause
you like,
look at Ohio,
it's all red,
but Cleveland's blue and like Columbus
is blue and Toledo's blue.
And so,
but the,
but the thing is all the,
just outside the city,
everyone's voting for trump,
but in the city,
people are voting for the brewing
Democrat.
But you look at,
if you look at Reagan's,
it's the,
I mean literally it's all fucking red.
Okay.